what are your thoughts on nepo babies
I mean look I she just said she was good
friends
no I come from she knows all of them
well it's but it's also like I'm the
opposite because it's like Michael
Patrick King said to me once he's so I
made the show Two Broke Girls with he
was like the problem with you is that
you're an outsider that looks like an
Insider and most of the Insiders look
like Outsiders so it was like Lena
Dunham like has connections to Hollywood
you know and then I don't at all but I'm
the one that gets all the [__] you know
so you know I don't how do you think
that is maybe I think I maybe want it
more I think that there's you don't
think there's I think that when you have
anything to do with the way you look and
the way that Lena looks I I that was
like not exactly half Jewish that's what
it is
whoever like I think that yeah that's a
much better when you come from money
you have the privilege of not being
desperate and I would like the show
would come out I would desperately be
like watch this please
I have two parents that had Strokes
without health insurance like I need to
sell these tickets it's Casino pajanga
like yeah and if you're a nepo baby
doing that you're like uh you're trying
to do it yeah people think you come from
money it's like why do you need so much
but I think people just couldn't wrap
around their heads that I come from you
know I had seven dollars do you think
people really have an issue with
nepotism or they have an issue with
themselves just not getting a role
Hollywood's never been like Fair why
should it be exactly it's like neither
Sports now this is a this is a [__]
wild take that the guys don't really
appreciate I think it's sorry can I say
something about it was in the middle of
a sense I know but I know but we're not
moving on it's about this it's about
this
the nepo babies parents right A lot of
them
got raped for their rules in Hollywood
so that their kids wouldn't have to work
so hard to get in Hollywood
so don't aren't they justified in the
same way that like akash's family comes
over here Works their ass off so that he
could be a comedian right like having
those families pay the ultimate price
for their kids to have it a little
easier yeah whereas like some actress
whose parents didn't get raped yeah
wannabe actress now all of a sudden
thinks she should just get the role yeah
but that's flawed inherently in that if
you're the dad that's famous you
probably did raping and didn't get raped
I don't believe it just the mom that's
famous I think is it just the mom that's
famous they should be able to be nepo
baby I think
I think they're very recent that's fair
say again I think consensual sex is a
very recent I'm really just talking
about this one two movement yes yes yes
yes yes
um I just think it's more I feel like it
was easy for those parents I think
anyone putting their children in acting
is a creep whether they were in it
whether they weren't in it
um I think it's bizarre like if you have
been in the business and I think it's
fair as a general and I think if you've
been in the business and you know what
it's about yeah you know and you put
your kid in it I think you're a worse
person but it's not about put your kid
because I think it's your form of
narcissism value it so much and like we
learned earlier with you you want to be
inside the box of your dad's who cared
so much about so imagine your parents
the only thing they talk about is film
TV movies this person doesn't deserve
this this person deserves that the only
thing that's important their whole world
is wrapped around it that's how you're
going to get the attention from these
parents who maybe not from in your life
that much is if you succeed the thing
that they're good at yeah I mean and I
think that like when I look at like the
actors that I know that you're kind of
referring to I just don't think they're
that as conscious you know I think that
that generation of like people in the
business like what they witnessed what
they saw like you know like I told the
story my last special about a director
uh that like took me into his trailer
when I was trying to get Taft heart lead
and you know he lunged at me and it was
like he was you know trying to do
something sexual with me I was like so
stunned and confused I I truly thought
he had like fell like it was like such
an uh like it was so like not there was
no build up there was no you know
touching the knee he just like lunged at
me and I was like are you okay like I
thought he had like a heart attack or
something how embarrassing it was to try
to rape someone and get sympathy dude it
was like so and then in that moment I
realized that I embarrassed him and it
was just and I'm like trapped with this
[__] that like never hears no
I'm like totally frozen I'm fine doesn't
matter but when you I look back at that
you know that it happened so many times
with so many girls and there were so
many people around that witnessed it now
that I've like run shows made movies or
on sets you're like at least like 30
people saw that because it's a lot of
people's job to know where the director
is so I think it's like even if you
haven't participated in some [__]
you've witnessed some [__] until in
any capacity want your kids to
participate in that especially girls
like I think it's just like a
narcissistic compulsion of like like I'm
famous and I want my kid to be famous
too or like I don't want to have to it's
like a trade of narcissism is that you
see your kids as an extension of
yourself like when I hear about a
celebrity that has a kid that I've never
seen on a red carpet you're like oh they
have another one that no one's seen I'm
like that's [__] awesome like
honestly the the person that I think has
handled being a nepo baby the best at
this point is Chad Hanks he's like I'm
I'm doing my thing dude
because to me it's also the way maybe
that they don't get Pride the same way I
drive Pride through everything I have I
earned I did it the hard way and like I
don't want anything I don't deserve like
that's just me personally I like grew up
on a lot of like cheating and you know
my mom like was for all intents and
purposes like um a gold digger you know
it was a lot of like we date this guy
and we get the stuff and I was like kind
of pressured today older man that would
like you know because they had a car
they could pick me up from school they
would like get her a watch and then it
was like don't [__] it up with this guy
you know it's just like I don't want
anything I don't deserve and I think if
you're born into a famous family you're
always gonna I mean it's like Paris
Hilton she works so hard she's an animal
because it's like she wants to be known
as her own thing and she has to work so
hard to get out from under the Hilton
name and it's kind of like just between
her and herself at this point because
like it doesn't feel good to her
to for people to go like well everything
she has is because of this like she's
trying to prove that she could have done
it without it and I think feeling that
like sucks I mean it was like a little
version for me is yeah you know when I
was like first um
you know on TV it was on Chelsea Handler
show you know and I was like oh God
doing this a lot obviously like I was
able to sell out clubs and I was like
able to like build a fan base whatever
but I was like am I always gonna feel
like I have this because
I was on Chelsea's show like what's
wrong with that nothing but I think I
have a thing in my head that's like oh I
just want to make sure I've earned it
all myself because but you know no one
earns it all yourself like I have so
much because of Charlemagne I have so
much because of Rogan I have so much
people the person that you showed up the
person you were on their shows but being
born as a nepo baby I just would always
hate myself just being like you know I
didn't get a chance to build something
on my own or no one is ever gonna yeah
but you were born pregnant
you were born smart that's an advantage